[Applause]
it's Rodeo season in Kodi where they say
the wild west was invented the cattle
has shown no mercy and they're not the
only ones here this week
[Applause]
in the Rough and Tumble of America's
polarized politics Wyoming Republicans
are preparing to unseat one of their
party's biggest names
at a rally outside the rodeo they've had
more than enough of Liz Cheney I hope
that she gets beat
because she has has become a traitor to
the people of Wyoming which is really
sad I pray to God that it will not be
close at all that we'll have who we want
and Liz will be gone
Liz Cheney has led investigations into
the January 6th assault on the capitol
committing the mortal sin for
Republicans of opposing Donald Trump
tonight I say this to my Republican
colleagues who are defending the
indefensible
there will come a day when Donald Trump
is gone
but your dishonor will remain
and shall be punished for it Republican
voters must choose between Cheney and an
opponent supported by Trump at the
polling station Cheney supporters were
hard to find do you think this journey
has a chance I hope not
you don't like her I do not I hope not
why is that
well I think she's a backstabber you
like her I love her for what she stood
up for absolutely there's a lot more at
stake in this election than the fate of
one politician if Liz chady loses badly
it'll show the strength of the grip that
Donald Trump has on the party and make
his comeback all the more likely Liz
Cheney's father former Vice President
Dick Cheney is supporting her with a
damning attack on Donald Trump in our
nation's 246 year history there has
never been an individual who has a
greater threat to our Republic than
Donald Trump
the Trump supporters he's no threat but
a patriot we joined them in a 71 Pontiac
festooned with Americana decorated with
500 silver dollars and 19 guns and wrote
it to Cody on the eve of the election
[Music]
come on
[Music]
at the wheel lifelong Republican Bob
Ferguson fervently hopes Donald Trump is
preparing to run again all the stuff
that's happened since he's been out of
office has probably convinced him more
and more that he he wants to be
president again and wants to to redeem
what uh what's been done against him
Donald Trump lurks and waits as he
Ponders a second coming he'll be
watching tonight's result closely
Dominic wagorn Sky News Wyoming